from a poster loving van to a feline
funny man with a serious snack food
addiction these Stars Tang their own
movies with their onset antics
I love troubled as a 1994 romantic
comedy co-written by the then married
Duo of Charles Shire and Nancy Myers
Shire also directed and Maya's served as
producer it stars Julia Roberts as a
young reporter and Nick Nolte as a
veteran journalist who joined forces to
uncover a conspiracy that involves
genetically altered milk the pair argue
constantly but develop a formidable
partnership alas the film was a loser of
both the box office and the Hmong
critics as it turns out the combative
nature of the two main characters was
apparently quite genuine in an interview
at the New York Times Roberts blamed the
naughty for a difficult working
environment on set she claimed that he
could be endearing one moment and
revolting the next while adding he seems
to go out of his way to repel people the
problem became so bad that the Los
Angeles Times reported that the pair
often refused to act together prompting
the crew to use stand-ins which may well
have contributed to their lack of
chemistry
a few decades ago Wesley Snipes was one
of the biggest action stars on the
planet but then he suffered a
spectacular Fall From Grace which
included a stint in prison for tax
evasion although he's managed to get
back on the upswing in recent years one
of the precursors says downfall happened
with 2004's blade Trinity the third
entry in the Marvel vampire franchise
also starred Ryan Reynolds Jessica Beale
and Patton Oswalt during a 2012
interview with the AV club Oswald
revealed that the entire production was
problematic and that much of that was on
Snipes as Oswald put it he wouldn't come
out of his trailer and he would smoke
weed all day Oswald also revealed that
Snipes got into a big fight with
director David S goyer prompting Goya to
hire bikers for security the feud was so
bad that the actor would only
communicate with the director through
Post-it notes which is obviously not the
most ideal way to make a movie and each
one he would sign blade
during the 80s and early 90s Dan Aykroyd
was one of the biggest names in comedy
after starring in iconic headset The
Blues Brothers and Ghostbusters he was
able to secure a deal to create the
bizarre comedy horror flick nothing but
trouble in 1991. it also ended up being
the one and only time you would direct a
feature film although it features plenty
of impressive acting Talent including
John Candy Demi Moore and Chevy Chase
have failed to make much of an
impression grossing just over 8 million
dollars at a domestic box office in a
1993 profile for New York Magazine Chase
explained that the movie was the kind of
project that could end someone's career
while also making a point of noting that
it was entirely acroid's concept not
only did he write and direct he also
played two different characters well
Chase put the blame for the movie's
failure on his friend's shoulders there
have also been questions raised about
his own Antics on the set
in 2010 Mickey Rourke starred in Passion
Play alongside Megan Fox Bill Murray and
Rhys evens Rock took the lead as a down
on his luck jazz musician who falls in
love with an exotic dancer and attempts
to rescue her from a violent gangster
after she's kidnapped despite The
Talented cast the film received scathing
reviews and grossed only 25
000 at the worldwide box office against
a budget of 15 million dollars walk was
actually originally quite complementary
about one of his co-stars telling E
online that fox was wonderful in the
film although he later appeared to
backtrack that sentiment when speaking
with vulture in 2011 he flat out
described the movie as terrible and then
seemed to suggest that fox might have
been part of the reason for that when
challenged about his previous
description of her as a great actor he
only smirked and responded that I worked
with that's obviously not the best way
to paint your co-star in a good light
this is the lady
I do for you
in 2006 this Annapolis a young man named
Jake played by James Franco is accepted
into the U.S Naval Academy struggling
academically and causing frustration
among the other recruits he eventually
wins back their loyalty and support by
performing impressively against second
Lieutenant Matthew Cole played by Tyrese
Gibson in a boxing tournament the movie
didn't exactly win over many critics
though Roger Ebert for one declared it
is the kind of film that has no visible
reason for existing except that
everybody got paid meanwhile it turns
less than 18 million dollars in total at
the worldwide box office if Gibson is to
be believed much of the failure lies at
Franco's feet in numerous interviews
since the film was released he's claimed
that Franco's method acting caused
problems on sets and even led to heated
arguments especially when Franco
actually punched his co-star as Gibson
put it bluntly in a 2007 Playboy
interview I never want to work with
Franco again and I'm sure he feels the
same way it felt very personal
the plenty of observers 1990s the
bonfire of the vanities must have looked
like a slum dunk director Brian De
Palmer was coming off a string of hits
and the movie was based on a
best-selling novel by Tom Wolfe it also
starred some big names like Tom Hanks
Bruce Willis and Morgan Freeman but it
didn't turn out quite so well as it made
back just 50 million dollars of its 47
million dollar Budget on top of the
disappointing box office bonfire was
also nominated for five golden raspberry
Awards including Melanie Griffith and
Kim Cattrall For Worse actress and the
worst supporting actress respectively
speaking about the movie years later
hence admitted that part of the reason
for its failure was that everyone in the
film including himself was miscast he
also made it clear that translating the
book itself to the screen was simply too
challenging
Mike Myers might not exactly be the
comedy superstar that he was in the late
90s and early 2000s but at least he
doesn't have a reputation as a jerk
however at least one of his co-stars
might dispute that Myers has starred in
a string of hits like Wayne's World
Austin Powers and Shrek before taking on
the role of the title feline in the 2003
adaptation of Dr Seuss says the Cat in
the Hat the movie also starred Amy Hill
as a children's original babysitter look
I'm a cat that can talk that should be
enough for you people during a 2016
interview with the AV club he'll claim
that Myers was a huge Diva who would
make the casting crew wait for a long
time before showing up on set she also
said that the cast had to do more takes
than necessary as miles would constantly
tell director Beau Welch that he wanted
to reshoot parts of the script he'll
even win so far as to reveal there was a
guy who held his chocolates in a little
Tupperware whenever he needed chocolate
he'd come running over and give him a
chocolate thus what Divas are like I
guess or people who need therapy
Val Kilmer has always had a bit of a
mixed reputation even from a young age
he was said to be something of a diva
and perfectionist so it shouldn't be too
surprising to learn that he's clashed
with a number of directors and fellow
actors over the years and his most
notorious Behavior may have happened
during the notorious he troubled
production of 1996's the island of Dr
Moreau a documentary lost soul the
doomed journey of Richard Stanley's
island of Dr Moreau touched upon some of
these issues Kilmer and his co-star
Marlon Brando reportedly almost came to
blows several times and filming was
delayed when the pair refused to work
with each other at one point Brando
allegedly told Kilmer your problem is
you confuse the size of your paycheck
with the size of your talent and it
wasn't just Brando who had a problem
with Kilmer as director John
frankenheimer told Entertainment Weekly
that he didn't want to work or interact
with the actor ever again
starring Ben Affleck and Jennifer Lopez
2003's G Lee is a mix of crime drama and
romantic comedy that was met with
widespread ridicule telling the story of
two Mobsters who are involved in a
botched kidnapping the protagonists
eventually end up becoming romantically
involved and escaped together often
regarded as one of the worst films ever
made it was also a huge box office
failure grossing only 7 million dollars
at the worldwide box office against a 75
million dollar budget the African Lopez
are so taken with each other they don't
need an audience good thing because
they're not going to get one not with
this stinker Aflac has since spoken
about how he believes both he and Lopez
carry some of the blame for G Lee's
terrible performance in a 2022 interview
with Entertainment Weekly he revealed
that his real-life relationship with his
co-star attracted too much attention to
the project this also led to the studio
deciding to add rom-com elements that
weren't originally part of the film
initially to take advantage of all the
Press coverage focused on the actors the
implication here of course is that if
Lopez wasn't after the production things
might have gone differently what makes
matters worse is that Lopez only got the
role after Halle Berry dropped out with
variety reporting that her commitment to
X-Men 2 clashed with Julie's proposed
shooting schedule
directed by Guy Ritchie 2017's King
Arthur legend of the sword is an epic
medieval action flick with fantasy
elements inspired by Arthurian Legends
slated to be the start of a brand new
blockbuster franchise it reportedly
instead ended up losing Warner Brothers
around 150 million dollars with
worldwide box office earnings of 148
million dollars against the 175 million
dollar budget even talented actors such
as Charlie Hunnam and Jude Law could do
little to save the movie which received
mostly mixed to negative reviews while
there are a whole host of reasons why
legend of the sword failed to meet
expectations Hunan believes there is one
notable cause that played a large part
while chatting with Andy Cohen during a
2020 radio interview he revealed that
one actor was miscast and had to be Kurt
from the final edit this ended up
wreaking havoc on the central storyline
and the character was ultimately absent
from the movie entirely Hunnam didn't
reveal what the cut scenes entailed or
who that particular actor even was
leaving this Legend a bit of a mystery
really missed an opportun was there to
tell a long form story in the 2018 crime
drama Billionaire Boys Club a group of
young men in the 1960s quickly find
wealth through a Los angeles-based Ponzi
scheme but then they soon find
themselves at the center of controversy
and implicated in the murder of a
character played by Kevin Spacey the
ensemble cast also included Taron
Edgerton Ansel Elgort and Emma Roberts
the film rubs production at the end of
2016 which was shortly before actor
Anthony Rapp made allegations of sexual
misconduct against Spacey more
accusations from other individuals
followed over the subsequent months as
police in Britain and the United States
began to investigate the actor the
controversy surrounding Spacey led to
Billionaire Boys Club having a very
limited theatrical release as it opened
in just 10 theaters in the US in an
interview the Sunday Telegraph Tyrone
Edgerton said that the movie was a
disappointment on multiple fronts as he
also admitted that its story may not
have been very appealing to moviegoers
however he also put much of the blame
directly on Spacey as he noted it it's
sad that his professional demise through
such a shadow over our film based on
this it's not hard to infer that
editorum believes that Spacey's Behavior
was effectively responsible for at least
some of the film's poor performance if
you or anyone you know has been a victim
of sexual assault help is available
visits the rape abuse and incest
National Network website or contact
Reigns National helpline at
1-800-656-hope 4673
[Music]